you hold the women's world record for
diving at altitudes both scuba and
freediving so I have to ask what can you
describe the details of those records I
never looked for those I I'm not after
records at all in fact I didn't know I
had broken those records when that
happened
um we did that as part of our Expedition
our scientific Expedition so it's
basically sport in the name of science
versus no it's science in the name of
Science and it's just a very physical
thing that you have to do so we train
ourselves like athletes yeah but to get
the job done to get the job done you're
holding your breath underwater for a
very long time like with free diving
what what are we talking about do you do
you think in terms of time is there like
layers where you know through training
you're in a good place like I'm sure you
take time off and you get rusty right I
and I have I have not been diving in a
while so probably I need to go back to
you know the drawing board and at the
bottom of the swimming pool but having
training from the past I think you know
it will pick up much more faster than
um basically I would never have those
altitude that would never go over three
minutes that would be suicidal so the
altitude is much tougher than the pool
back at ground level
it is but it's because when you come up
yeah that's not the going in the water
when I'm on the water I'm fine and if I
wanted I could stay longer but it
wouldn't be very wise